my leg
welcome to BuzzFeed's running out of
ideas the new show that you guys have
all been begging for what we did is took
a bunch of popular keywords and put them
on some dice then we're going to roll
those dice and whatever the combination
of words it lands on is the title of our
video so let's get to it
I'm here with the team we're ready to
roll the dice and find ourselves a video
whoa
ready one two three a hundred yes condom
rah smash I like it what does that mean
we could make a bra out of 100 condoms
and fill them with things I'm gonna drop
them off the roof does that you're a
genius
look at that freeze it with it yeah we
could freeze it with liquid nitrogen and
smash it bra made of 100 condoms freeze
it smash it
we could use colored condom condoms I
think would break flavor class as long
as the condom smash we have the 100
condom products I decide a bra on you
know a lot of bras are just out there
for pretty miss that's you okay I think
we've got a video come
[Music]
the day has come it is time for 100
condom bra smash we're ready to kill it
kill the bras and the Internet
[Music]
three-two-one
that didn't do anything no that's
[ __ ] that didn't totally go as
planned but this time we're going to try
a different approach we're gonna dunk
the bra in water first and then freeze
it with the liquid nitrogen see if that
makes any kind of a difference we don't
know we're just trying stuff we're
winging it flying by the seat of our
pants or something whatever they say
[Music]
that is frozen solid Oh 3 2 1 now you
can put on the table there you go there
you go
well 100 condom brah smash its a video
that's kind of neat that was kind of
boring